welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and zack snyder's justice league is
days away from big announcements about
its hbo max director's cut with snyder
posting countdown teases keeping us
guessing how he's gonna bring back the
fur on henry cavill states
and i assume the fur on every two square
inch in this movie
because you know none of them shaved for
the reshoots these posts by snyder
actually point to some of the biggest
changes his
justice league restoration is expected
to include so ahead of the upcoming
trailer which we will be breaking down
for you frame by frame when it comes out
please end this trial with some trailers
soon we're gonna do here with the snyder
diehards i've been doing for the past
two and a half years
and assembling the true dream snyder cut
in our mental head cannons based on
clues
dropped by snyder on social media with
another tweetdown
zack snyder posted a teaser set photo of
the ruins of wayne manor
counting down to six days until the
snyder cut footage comes out at dc's
fandom
i think we are all thankful that he
waited until sunday because if it was
saturday it'd be seven days and i
definitely would have read it in the
voice of the girl from the ring
now why is this set photo so important
well you may remember this setting
first from batman v superman when bruce
told alfred that hunty and superman
might be the most important thing in the
wayne family legacy considering they
started as fur traders
they were hunters so falls the hearts of
wayne
and then the theatrical cut of justice
league brought that full circle
a much sunnier time of day with alfred
bruce and diana setting up the mansion
as the new headquarters of the justice
league
big round table six chairs right there
but room for more room for more damn
jamie irons ain't been so happy since
watching his brother mufasa fall into
the stampeding wildebeest but in the
snyder set photo let's zoom enhance on
that green screen
background there it is almost as if zack
snyder suggesting he planned to have
something more to this scene maybe just
planned it cgi the whole 150-foot deep
ballroom or maybe in the middle of that
ballroom will be an
already arranged table with more than
six chairs
the reason you should be excited about
this is that before snyder stepped down
from justice league in early 2017
promotions for the movie
included the phrase unite the seven the
josh sweden recut the actual release of
justice league featured
six members batman wonder woman aquaman
flash cyborg
by the end of it of course superman but
never introduced a seventh member no
green lantern no martian manhunter now
in the years after schneider has
revealed original plans
to reveal general swanwick harry linux's
character from man of steel batman
superman
as martian manhunter in disguise and
since the announcement of snyder's
justice league coming to hbo max next
year
lennox has hinted that the director's
cut will confirm that now we've also
heard reports that there was a planned
post credit scene
showing green lantern core members
kilawog and tamare visiting bruce at his
lakeside mansion to warn him about
darkseid's arrival
and at last month's justice league panel
zack snyder acknowledged that he
included logos for green lantern and
martian manhunter on the merch apparel
for the project
sure did do that didn't that now while i
do not expect
snyder's justice league to show bruce
swinging open those doors to an already
cast tile jordan green lantern sitting
there at the table spinning his ring
it would not be out of the question for
there to be a table with
exactly seven or exactly eight chairs
and not this tv
room for more [ __ ] you can't just
save room for more you gotta be specific
because otherwise jared leto is gonna
crash into these musical chairs you mean
room for more of this on gonka
there was another interesting photo
leaked by snyder look uncovering these
truths have taught me it's never been a
better
time to learn something new but in that
process of self-education there are
thousands of options available and
finding the best way to learn can be
tough that is why i've been really
loving this app called
blinkist thanks to blinkist for
sponsoring this video blinkist gives you
the best
key takeaways from over 3 000 nonfiction
bestsellers in over 27 categories
blinkist condenses them all into
blinks which you can read or listen to
in just 15 minutes on your phone your
tablet or in your web browser
blinkist also offers its members
exclusive original content from top
authors and creative thinkers over 14
million people
use blinkist to deepen their knowledge
in topics like self-improvement
leadership mindfulness happiness and
more i like blinkists because it can be
hard to carve out the time to read a
full book or audiobook but with blinkist
i can get the need to know info
from an interesting book in just 15
minutes flat you could knock out like
seven books in the time it would take
you to do another rewatch of the matrix
that i do every week to keep my mind
free few titles that i've really enjoyed
recently include why we sleep by matthew
walker
and the courage to be disliked by iricio
kishimi and right now blinkist has a
special offer
just for our audience all you gotta do
go to blinkist.com
to start your free seven day trial and
get 25 off a blinkist premium membership
and up to 65 off audiobooks that are
yours to keep forever
that's blinkist spelled b l
b-l-i-n-k-i-s-t
blinkist dot com slash new rock stars to
get 25 off a premium membership and a
seven day free trial
blinkist.com new rockstars okay the
other recent image schneider shared
featured him with stefan sunfeld
a film colorist at post-production house
company 3. if you look closely at his
screen
it shows what appears to be the
confrontation in heroes park between
superman and the rest of the justice
league
those are the feet of victor berry diana
and arthur but what i find interesting
about this
is when you go back to watch the justice
league theatrical cut
this exact shot is nowhere in that kind
of the movie this is a completely new
angle and notice the aspect ratio this
is 143-1
also known as the more vertical imax
aspect ratio
not the more common widescreen that we
didn't reframed everything in for the
theatrical release snyder explained last
month that his original vision for
justice league was an imax aspect ratio
so that the frame could include more of
the vertical
action and not prop out key pieces of
information now coloring is a standard
step in post-production something lead
editors and directors will do right
before a cut of something releases to
the public to make sure all the shots
have a consistent color temperature that
matches the film's overall palette
like you don't want superman seat vision
to be fiery orange in one shot and then
ruby crimson in another and i bring up
the coloring here because notice the
bolts of electricity around cyborg and
flash there to many it looks as though
they might be adjusting the coloring on
flash's speed force one of the many
areas of frustration fans had with
theatrical release that barry allen
speed force is kind of a just
trail that he leaves behind that doesn't
even realize is coming out of him as
opposed to you know a force that he
consciously weaponizes along with his
speed from what we can tell
a lot about this justice league skirmish
in heroes park is going to play out
real different with several insiders
reporting kal-el is going to be much
more unhinged in this fight
other reports are saying that this film
was going to kill off lois lane
further enraging superman closer to that
dark superman nightmare
the one that flashed in the future
warned bruce wayne about with lois being
the key as in prevent her death and you
won't get this future
hopefully this means that the snyder cut
version of the scene won't end with you
know that
joss whedon age of ultron style sun's
getting real low
between superman and lois maybe an even
darker ending of lois's accidental death
followed by superman finding his black
suit which isn't just to be darker edgy
in the comics he uses it to help restore
his strength after his death
and then he checks back in with alfred
as snyder has shown in the other leaked
footage now in theatrical cut the hero's
park fight did come off as a bit stilted
in my opinion other than clark's awesome
side eye to barry
there's just a lot of moments of
convenient one-on-ones when it wasn't
really clear where everyone else was in
that moment it just didn't have the
urgency or desperation that
other superhero dog piles on god level
did i'm sorry i'll stop comparing it to
those guys but hey we know the
theatrical version of this was pieced
together by a marvel interloper so i
think the criticism is fair
we are in the middle of dc week here at
new rockstars so we
will be digging even deeper into the
snyder cut when more details come out
along with robert patton since the
batman
wonder woman 84 james guns suicide squad
shazam 2 aquaman 2 and we got a re-watch
and analysis of snyder's ultimate
edition
of batman beast superman coming this
friday so if you love dc it has never
been a better time to subscribe to new
rockstars
and join us for our batman v superman
live watch along on our discord tomorrow
you can do that by becoming a patron at
patreon.com newrockstars follow me on
instagram
boss thanks for watching
[Music]
you